all right tennessee lawmakers sounding
the alarm after local reports claim that
the biden administration
is secretly flying unaccompanied migrant
kids
into tennessee in the middle of the
night without
telling the local authorities republican
tennessee congressman mark green
wants answers from the white house and
he joins us now from nashville
congressman good morning hey steve
thanks for having me on
so there's a story that apparently they
are flying these kids
into airports like in chattanooga
unannounced they didn't
uh notify local authorities why would
that
be why wouldn't they give you guys a
heads up hey we're we're doing the migra
uh process we're gonna bring them into
tennessee why wouldn't they tell you
well first steve you know how do we get
here we got here because
joe biden did away with the asylum
agreements and the guard
the drug cartels are grabbing these
children coming across south uh
central america dumping them at our
border and getting into our country
basically biden's
facilitating human trafficking and then
they got to figure out what to do
so they call i spoke to our governor
last night about this
issue he's done a very good job keeping
us informed
he was called two weeks ago by the biden
administration and asked do you want to
take
you know these uh migrants these illegal
migrants and he said no we do not want
to take them
so that's why they're having to sneak
them into tennessee because we told them
you can't just
bring them here without our permission
and they're doing it anyway
well you know about a month or so ago
kim reynolds the governor of iowa was
asked can we bring kids to iowa and she
said no
we don't know if they're flying them
into waterloo under the cover of
darkness but we do know that that is
happening
in tennessee but you would think that
the government would ask
the state uh for permission and they
would have to be granted it because
we know that you know thousands of
migrants
on your doorstep could be a huge
financial
uh you know could suck a lot of money
out of your state coffers
sure absolutely it's an unfunded mandate
you think about it i was a state senator
and we looked at the costs of the
refugee program
you know years ago you have to you know
english as a second language the states
have to pay for that in their education
systems
and all the myriad of other things you
can give them to non-profits which is
essentially what
you know the body administration is now
doing but the taxpayer winds up paying
this bill
and their man basically it's an unfunded
mandate
by the federal government it fits
completely though
with the joe biden leftist mentality
that all power should reside in
washington dc right and they can just
ignore that 10th amendment and
force tennessee to do this well we've
got a statement from
the hhs but they do not address why uh
they're flying kids into
tennessee they say as part of the
unification process the office
is currently facilitating travel for the
children in
custody to their sponsors to prevent any
delays
contractors use various transportation
modes to get them wherever they're going
but that doesn't say
why they're not telling you guys
meanwhile let's talk a little bit about
this
uh if he looks lighter it's because he's
five hundred dollars lighter
you gotta find for not wearing a mask on
the house floor because nancy pelosi
unlike the senate where you don't have
to wear a mask
she says you've got to wear a mask
although we saw her yesterday i believe
it was at the white house and she
doesn't have a mask there congressman
what is she trying to prove
because some say she's just trying to
rub republicans
noses in this because all the democrats
are vaccinated
and not all the republicans are yeah
steve this is the definition of
hypocrisy you know
leadership 101 at west point for me 35
years ago the first thing they teach you
is you never ask people to do something
you as the leader aren't willing to do
and here she is
in the house at the at the you know
speaker's roster
not wearing a mask she goes to the white
house not wearing a mask
yet she's you know keeping this very
unscientific
i mean we all know if you're vaccinated
the cdc came out with this you don't
have to have a mask
they are forcing it even in committee
she basically compelled the house
physician to change his rule his knee
jerk response
to the cdc was hey let's let's not wear
masks in committee
she came back he had to retract that and
change it i mean it's just
uh harassment basically so you're saying
she pressured the attending physician to
change the rules
i i can't imagine why a physician would
come out with one rule
there were no studies in the in four
days
you know i'm speculating why he as a
physician would change
his clinical guidance well don't get
caught not wearing a mask again or it's
2500 bucks out of your pocket
that's right steve all right congressman
we thank you very much for joining us
today in nashville